bài hát anh đi nhậu rồi
Ừ tôi đăng bài có kêu đi nhậu
đi nhậu nhỉ
anh không hiểu à
anh không nhiều video này đi ra gì À đây
mà nó chuột
thì các bạn thử nghe thử nhé
I
Were You Again again It is the one
hundred thousand and public When
he was doing that were Avengers
Adidas
[Vỗ tay]
again It is the one hundred thousand
ensiferum
understand what going that were Avengers
or you
Ừ cái video này tôi thấy khá hay về
cho bạn nào chưa hiểu thì đi dạo này câu
hỏi của nó hỏi đó là
một là mày có thể tung đồng xu và có cơ
hội được chúng một triệu đô hay là được
100.000 đô ngay lập tức kiểu nó chắc
chắn ấy thì ông kia bảo là chọn là tung
đồng xu rồi Bảo là tại sao mày ở trọng
thế rõ ràng cái kia nó đảm bảo hơn bởi
vì mày có thể không không được gì cả
đi theo người bảo là một triệu đô thì
thay đổi cuộc đời cũng đấy 100.000 đô
thì nó trái hưởng gì lắm và
và bản thân ông ấy đang không có gì rồi
về cơ bản thì nếu không có gì thì thôi
nghĩa là mù đã thay đổi hẳn số phận mình
hay là kệ giữ nguyên Thế còn như không
gì xảy ra cả Không ạ Đây là một cái quan
điểm gạ khá hay đó là
A và đôi khi thứ nhất khi là chúng ta à
em đổi tôi rất nhiều lúc tôi hiện thưởng
này nghĩ đó là kiểu Giả sử mình có không
biết mấy hôm nhờ nghĩ việc đấy Không là
kiểu Giả sử mình có Thần đèn 2 của ba
đứa cái gì đó Mình có một điều ước gì đó
thì mới ông gỡ cái điều gì alo
Ừ tự nhiên hàng YouTube xoay xoay
ờ ờ ổn định hơn rồi đúng không
Ừ OK OK thì
Nếu giả sử hồi đầy Tôi nghĩ rằng à
nhà mình có điều ước nóng ạ thì mình nên
ước cái gì cho nó kiểu nó nó kiểu dạng
là nó tránh bài toán rủi ro nó cũng hiểu
gì tôi ông ạ cậu đã từng có khá nhiều có
phim nói với nó có điều ước rồi cùng thì
nó để nó cũng gây ra một cái hậu quả gì
đó vẩn nên thường ở Tôi không muốn ước
một cái gì đó lắm ở thời sự như thế Tôi
muốn à Thôi muộn là kể cả cuộc sống có
may mắn hay đến đổi nghĩa là không tôi
Tôi không muốn dùng được may mắn nên đổi
mà gần như ở Đối với tôi thì nghĩ à
là mình sinh ra thế nào quan trọng Quan
trọng lúc mà mình chết đi mình sẽ phải
làm được cái gì đó
đấy Cái đây cái lúc mình chết đi thì
mình mình cây cái cuộc đời của mình lại
do mình quyết định Còn lúc mình sinh ra
là không phải do mình cố định đúng không
ạ do người khác với định sinh ra cũng có
thể nghèo
Thật ra tôi không muốn dụng từ Giàu
Nghèo đây cả sinh ra ông có thể như nào
đấy không quan trọng kiểu môi trường lao
động vân Nhưng mà về sau thì đó do con
người ông thôi nó con người ông nhìn
nhận sự việc như thế nào nhưng nhìn và
hành động như thế nào để mà con người
ông trở thành con người như nào
Ừ thế này là tội không muốn ước cái gì
cả tôi Thứ nhất là tôi không ở nước hay
ở Tôi sẽ không bao giờ ân hận về mình vì
mình à đã làm gì đó mà tôi thường ạ tôi
thường hay nghĩ là chúng ta đôi khi phải
cân nhắc việc là ân hận khi không làm
cái gì đó nên là thực ra là ví dụ là sử
gia sử nhé là thích ai tự sẽ nói ra
chẳng hạn Tôi thích hay Tôi muốn làm cái
gì đó sẽ là thế Miễn là không để lại hậu
quả mẹ là không không phải thích ngoại
thích người đã có bồ không để quả đâu
nhỉ hoặc à
Nói chung là cố
sự cố sống cuộc sống ở để 16 không ân
hận mà để về sau có cái để mà mình nhìn
lại thì mình trân trọng nó chứ không
phải mình được nghĩ là nó rất tồi tệ
không ạ Tức nghe nữa Rất khó để mở có
một cuộc sống như thế Tôi may mắn là tôi
rồi Hiện tại thì thế là trộm có
tục có rất nhiều sai lầm trong quá khứ
nhưng tôi toàn lấy đấy coi nó bài học
hơn là Tuấn hận một cái gì đó không ăn
hại gì cả Sao bao nhiêu số tiền mình bỏ
ra cho gái nhưng mà mình vẫn không có
này
nó nghĩa cũ là những người thầy tốt nhất
Ngoại
nó bạn kia nói hay không dùng từ ước mơ
đúng ạ Mà mục tiêu có thứ
anh gửi cho tôi mục tiêu nhiều đám hỏi
bé kiểu gì chẳng có ước mơ mục tiêu gì
gì đó nó lên thì tôi tự nhiên thay đổi
nhiều mục tiêu rồi còn nhiều mục tiêu
thôi nghĩa sẽ nó hơi miền vong và cũng
như là không thể làm hết để trong một
đời người nên tôi bỏ qua
thế Nhưng bản chất con người thì mình
thì vẫn thế mình sẽ
mình đấy Giả sử là mình vẫn làm được
những thứ mình thích mình muốn về tuổi
trẻ mình vẫn làm được những thứ mình
thích
ở đại tôi nghĩa mấy ông mấy ông còn trẻ
không tôi mà Mấy ông làm được vừa đấy nó
giờ tốt
không ạ à
I have to squeeze học của tôi được tôi
không hẳn chuyên dạy các bạn sub lắm các
bạn thể lên cốc ta có takamiya vài trang
gì đó lại họp ra Speed nhưng mà nên được
hàng nhiều học Lịch trình này à thực
hành nhiều xong rồi mình từ từ hiểu lý
thuyết
khi đọc nhiều lý thuyết quá bị quá tải
cho tôi như thế
tôi ít dùng từ không thể lắm ra mình
muốn thì mình vẫn có tìm cách để làm
chẳng qua là mình nên ưu tiên cái gì
trước thôi
đi Câu hỏi thì thực ra là có vài câu hỏi
tôi nghĩa để buổi sau với cháu nữa tôi
mới xin phép trả lời chứ
cho chú vài câu thì hoa cà vài câu mà
khi mà đến bài đấy tôi sẽ trả lời nó hợp
lý hơn à Hôm nay mình sẽ làm tiếp hôm
trước làm giờ ông ạ Chưa đang làm dở Cái
bên A
thế này - skin
chị sẽ hiển thị gia ngoại
Ừ để tôi xe máy
từ trước định không chia sẻ màn hình mà
Kìa nghĩa là cô hộ hôm chưa đơn giản
thôi dễ mà cứ cùng thì dài vãi chưởng
mày sẽ chia sẻ màn hình cho máy ông nhé
mũi tí ở khung thành ảo chồng giờ phức
tạp nước màu mè Ok
không trước mẹ làm xong rồi cái giao
diện cân đối như thế này đúng
Ờ Ờ
mình thì ra được bài đăng có thứ
cái này nên là phân Cha tôi sẽ biến nó
thành kiểu phần trai nhé chị đã tí Đợi
tí nha
Ừ đợi lại đầu tiên này mình sẽ mở
control to làm cái con trai không ạ
a beacon Palace
bộ bikini hùng trước đã làm phần Khanh
rồi nhưng mà mình chưa hiển thị ra rồi
con trai mình sẽ làm cái hiển thị
sẽ có
đề thay vì classf more này không ạ
Đâu tui Loan Mau rồi
đi đám ma
Á đù mỏ
ở đập thủy lợi gì nhé
a web Bác
Ừ cái mặt sau của nó
về mặt xã hội thằng này hôm trước mình
chưa làm đây mà sau ngoại
rossmore bay rồi nhỉ nó mỏi nhưng ở
ngoài
này
tôi sẽ tổng nó bên trong này đi nhưng mà
nó nằm ngoài cái đi pro rồi để xem nhé
Để xem nào
khi con tên
ở Dak Lak Mori Tống ở bên trong này nó
hợp lý hơn này
sẽ biết dâu luôn này
Ừ ok ok
Ờ Ờ cái này sẽ cho ra ngoài nhưng ai
toàn bộ Cái này
khi chờ trong ngày
ok rồi thì à anh sẽ nhắn ngay thôi
cái lót mô này mình sẽ thay bản chất rồi
hôm trước tôi có bảo là mình sẽ làm phân
trang ah
Anh dùng cả phân trang của
Ê thằng ngày
à à Thế thanhthanh menu này nó theo
nhưng mà nó đang bị giao diện trắng
chống tệ nhỉ
Khi
bữa xài cái thằng này nó biến thành như
này hình như là
Hì hì nhờ dress nó sẽ đổi màu
em đổi màu cái này
Ừ tôi có thể để bỏ cái này picture cho
đỡ chồng khó chịu ở nhà vui vì kéo xuống
hơi khó chịu nghỉ à
ừ ừ
anh xem mà load More
Ừ chúc mừng sang giao diện ở cà ra
xe Vespa Schneider
Ừ
thôi nghĩa tôi sẽ dùng cái này bởi vì à
Ai trông
chỉ có mỗi hai đi ỉa đi nghỉ đi
[âm nhạc]
anh hiểu ra đi
em chọn cái này
à à
có thể khác nhau rồi
anh ngắm
Ừ ok rồi vào lại bấm nhầm rồi
à
mà lại
ờ ờ
Ok copy class vậy
a-class này
thì mình sẽ có
a
post xong rồi trọ đến link ngay thì phải
Âm Nhạc
à à
mà tại sao lại khác nhỉ Oh kệ cũng chẳng
a nay có thể đẩy mình để size nó
Em nạp flash Drive
à
nhờ có vẻ nó đang bị à à
ở Arsenal
có like đoạn này nhỉ
cho iPad a55
155 độ tội lỗi tôi à
Thế ra tông màu không nên như này ông
ngồi
-1 là ông tông màu hiểu ở đây nó có
nhiều cái tô màu gì rồi ông một trang Mỹ
màu hơi đừng có nút này thì màu này nút
kia mày kia nhé Nó không nên Ờ
thì tôi xem nhé Để xem à
Khi nào Switch Hồ Chí Minh hôm trước và
mình in ra ở đây in ra ở đây nó lại
không có mày còn language Mình chưa có
cái á
đúng không ạ Company ngoan thì đây mình
sẽ
Ừ tôi đã sẽ quay di dùng để nó xuống
dòng cho đỡ đi
ăn gì đây đầu tiên cả với cả lắm quyết
để tôi cứ đ.d thử cái posts a cho bé
uống xem nhé
ô tô arrange A
dễ hình dung hơn đi và cái này sẽ ra
mình mặc định Limit ra xử xử đó nhá Đi
Mít là 10A
Ê mày ông sẽ thấy da nó trả lời hết toàn
bộ thông tin Ok rồi này Thực ra có vài
cái thông tin không nên chả phê nhưng mà
đang có mặc định trở về
tiếp theo 15 which này
Ừ thì ông thấy ở đây là thứ ra là nó có
trả phải gặp ai phốt ra mình không cần
máy bay vus mình thật sự mình chỉ muốn
lấy à Hay đi về nên thôi mình có thể đi
dạo này hình như thế rồi nhé
Vì sao mặc định hàng ngày nó cứ phải là
vai vợ
tao nó phải thông qua mà không sao nhưng
mà với với bài thằng mình sẽ lấy thông
tin là sự là mình sẽ chỉ lấy đúng một
vài trường của nó là dở cho mình xem ở
đúng là mình chỉ muốn lấy ai đi lên ID
phải luôn lấy vì nó là nó là chúng nó là
cái khóa nối sẵn hàng kia phải luôn lấy
ID nêm này mình sẽ có thể thêm à
Cho tôi xem đi street City ở đây có rồi
Tao muốn hiển thị ra ở giao diện đấy sẽ
this city ở đằng sau khi mình bấm nữa
xem thêm này sẽ nhìn thấy làm sau cái đi
ship và City ngờ của cái port ấy chứ Mà
của
đi của Paul âm nhạc ngoài của post chứ
không phải là của cậu có đi đâu và logo
của logo có phải nhịn cần này mình sẽ
đây là with Company nha
Đi
Tìm Tôi đặt đây Ê bà most Night
đăng ký hiệu nó trả về cái gì mà thôi
tiếp theo mình sẽ có
có một bài đăng thì thuộc một Company
ngoại lệ company
thoảng bị nát thật à
tên đô la gi I
ờ ờ
hàng thôi thì sẽ có không phân li ở đây
[âm nhạc]
Nhờ cái này là tính đa hình hôm trước
mình làm Bởi vì bản chất mình sẽ phải
làm là Ê thằng = offset language này nó
sẽ vừa là vợ là của bài đăng nhưng có
lúc đó sẽ là của cả của cả ý của cả gì
nhé
Khi bữa trước mà mình định làm củ cả
thằng gì nhé
cà phê ai à hai của cậu Út ơi
nhớ Thế ở chung nhà tình ta hình sẽ có
hai cái tính năng hình trong trường mày
phải một cái thằng này vì sau mình có
report này cũng thế part 2 mình quên
được sửa lại đấy đấy thì cái đặt tên của
mình sẽ ra đặt tên được các loại ô Black
sao để nó thêm cái gạch dưới Thay vào
như này nữa thôi nó sẽ tự động điền hộ
mình cái à tự động Điền hội ngày này thì
cho mình phải sửa lại bên emminh rồi mà
để làm lại thì vụ update cái đoạn mà
language
a tiếp theo ngày
cho thuốc về
a Company này
đi tìm cái này mình sẽ with Company bao
da sữa mình sẽ lấy nêm cách viết có sẽ
hay hiểu biết Mùa Đông sẽ biết thì kiểu
như này
Ừ kiểu như này Thực ra thì về sau sử ấy
thì khi mà không có mít cốt khi ông đầy
cốt lên
ở nhà sự thì nó sẽ luôn hiểu là nó sẽ
luôn bị cái tình trạng này là ông xóa
cái dòng này đi không xong rồi kể cả
cháu trông về xong thêm một trường nữa
khi nó thì thằng này nó luôn Hiểu nó
luôn thông báo là ông đã Xóa dòng mới đi
học thay dòng mới thôi đôi khi tao không
thích kiểu đấy tôi sẽ thường hay kiểu
làm kiểu như này
vợ chồng nó dài dòng hơn nhưng mà gỡ à
nó sẽ trực quan dễ nhìn hơn
Ừ Vậy thì đợi tí
3 cách viết của tôi Thượng trên công ty
ở sẽ cho anh ngay nhé bản chất là thằng
này nó sẽ lành mạnh ngay cơ
anh ở đây sẽ phẳng chân này
anh Quý anh ạ
xin lỗi vi Tôn
ý là đôi khi không có Twitter nằm chờ
ngày thì phải ạ
thế quỳ
ở đây và lên mình sẽ để mạnh nha Ai đi
này lên này Logo
giờ sửa mình muốn thêm hàng nữa là mình
sẽ chỉ cần đã ký kết nào lên là xong đấy
thì nó sẽ khi mình có mít khi để có lên
thì mình sẽ hiểu được mình thêm hoặc là
xóa lòng là đi chứ không phải là cứ mỗi
lần mình ko bít thêm một cái mới là nó
xóa cái dòng này đi thì người khác người
sau nhìn vào sẽ rất khó hiểu không biết
được nó phải đọc kỹ cho em mà ông đã
thêm ông thêm cái sửa cái gì để hạn chế
điều đấy xảy ra
Company 13 chương này nó Ngoại Ô
tắt bên này tắt bên này tôi sẽ có đây
tôi sẽ sửa lại đây sẽ là
em mệt hay thồ này Thế thì tôi sẽ phải
gọi đến cái thằng à Vợ tôi thì đợi chứ
nó sẽ có một hàng hôm trước mình làm
mình có thằng câm Vân lần nữa nó một lần
đâu nhỉ ở đây
thì mình sẽ truyền vào đây những cái
thằng nào đây Mình có thể truyền thẳng
là rụt hay thồ này để xem nhé
Ừ cái này à Company company
Ừ ông ông có thể để đây uncheck cũng
được
Thật sự đây Office Company
này sau đó thì ông hoàn toàn Company
ngay Sao ông gọi đến hàng á posts
đó thì ở bên này ông sẽ khai báo là con
bớt đi nha
ở sông chó đến nêm đó con ở đây ông in
ra thì ông sẽ cho đến Company tại logo
hạn thế
Cái này cái gì đấy
Ừ tối thử bỏ bê đề đây nha mày không xem
nhé
không có hàm Linh
à à
này
a logo lên à cái ảnh này bị lỗi không có
đúng chưa thức có có ảnh hết đấy
chỉ cần bấm vào
chỉ cần bấm vào đây để mà quay đằng sau
đúng không
Ê mày đằng sau thì
vì vậy xem nhé
ví dụ của cái cái bên này là cái gì nhỉ
cái clip ô ồ kompany cái gì nhỉ
xoài thoải mái đi ừ
anh em xem nha
12 vip của thằng đang cố định cho không
thích điều này
a
Mình sẽ hiển thị ra ở đây sẽ hiển thị ra
được cái gì ở đây nào à
vào để xem thêm hay là tải luôn file
luôn ở đây được nha xem nhé ờ ờ ờ
a parttime anh Hiển thị luôn những cái
remote Apple gặp parttime ở đây luôn nhỉ
xem nó nhanh Thường mấy cái đấy tôi nghĩ
à
đi tìm kiếm được
từ trước đây nóng Tìm kiếm được
đi theo mấy ông ấy nên hiển thị gì cả Ở
đằng sau
dùng hai cái đôla 2k đôla đấy nó sẽ biến
thành xinh thôi
biết được nhưng hiển thị gì ở đằng sau
này
có thể đi ship với City cho bạn nha đơn
giản nhé
có thể à để
biến nó thành áo che kiểu tốt như này
luôn cũng được nhưng mà không được
Âm Nhạc
à à
Ừ thì
ông in ra nó dễ ngày
ở
Nga trở lại
vì vậy tâm sự thế Ở dưới mình sẽ có
location
a location à
à à
ạ sau đó thì đây mình sẽ có mà
What cho đến City
lên à
Hình như là không lấy được a job title à
sau khi bị trường hợp này hơi khó chịu
nghỉ à
như này Thực ra là tôi nghĩ là bởi vì nó
là ít em khác nhiều ý nghĩa tôi sẽ ghét
tôi sẽ tạo một cái chai bia ở đây Ghét
nó nhanh đi ghét a location
IQ
mình sẽ là ở đây là à
chỉ quan tâm đến việc nếu mà
Ừ nếu mà không chấm cái à
Anh đùa zid beatrice thôi không Chồng
tỉnh thì mình sẽ yên tĩnh là kèm theo
cái dấu gạch
dưới các thứ dấu cách giữa ạ
Ừ
kiểu gì này
sau đó mình sẽ chỉ gọi lên chỉ cần gọi
đến A lô cái sân này được
anh ngoan chưa
game dễ ngoạn nhiên dễ
Anh Bình Sony mình sẽ xử lý hết ở Bắc em
ngọn con em mình chị đã lại thì chị ra
thôi ý mà
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ làm à phân xanh Tìm
kiếm mình sẽ tìm kiếm cái này 7 để cái
tìm kiếm nên hai địa chỉ là có nhà thành
công rồi mình mình mỗi khi mình tìm kiếm
cái gì đó này mình sẽ bắt sự kiện để một
đầy nói 2 địa chỉ sau đó thì mình sẽ lấy
cái vi quét đấy để mình sẽ fito đây mình
sẽ Peter nó một là thế hai mình sẽ làm
ảo giác mày nhưng tôi nghĩ à Để em hay
địa chỉ một cái do hai mà nhiều người bị
lạm dụng nghĩa rất quá thì
sau khi mình copy cái đường link này cho
người khác thì nó sẽ mất đi cái tìm kiếm
đấy mà mình nên thế nên là có hai nơi
thường hay làm buồn nào đấy 2 địa chỉ
sau đó lại tra dùng pp thuần hay là để
Hà vẫn dụng iPad nhưng mà vẫn đẩy dùng
ra suy về hàng địa chỉ
khá nhiều nơi làm cái cái thứ hai nhưng
cái khó hơn mà việc Cái đấy phải
Facebook WordPress để làm lừa đấy à
à Còn bây giờ tôi dùng kiểu giá ship
thuần nghỉ thì cả hơi khó làm được thì
tôi nghĩ à Đi chơi cà phê p giờ nông dân
đỡ phải xử lý nhiều đoạn này dễ mình sẽ
cứ mỗi lần mình kéo cái này hay mình bấm
bấm tích rồi thế này thì nó sẽ nó lại ra
hơi bị dở hơi bị khó chịu một tí nhưng
mà thôi Làm những nông dân mà không
phải reset
xem nha đầu tiên đầu tiên trước mắt đấy
Đó là cái cái hiển thị ra ở hai cái bên
này như thế này thì được ca là mấy cái
filter này đáng lẽ Đáng lẽ là phải có
phải mặc định mà mình sẽ phải theo cái
thằng này để ra được những phi tôn này
nóng lạnh nhà tôi sẽ tôi bắt đầu tôi sẽ
sửa lại bình xịt ơ nhá á
đầu tiên cái chuyện này hoặc bỏ qua lâu
sinh này lâu tinh đến tận
ở đâu nhỉ lâu thì nhìn đây là sửa xóa ED
Zalo này có rất nhiều không ạ Cũng như
chiếc bóng
ừ ừ
3 năm sau làm span đấy nhỉ
có tư tưởng sai mà
ở lại Việt Nam Ơi
Ừ ok
em ở ấp mất pin rồi
I can see that sends a
Anh Phan
à à
ở đó
không Để ý kỹ nó bị lệch đúng kệ ờ
cái số ở đây trước đã số này đóng
chú voi lừa đấy à
nó data QC không biết về cái này
bộ đội cho gì Cái gì quan trọng đâu nhỉ
Xóa đi thức là nó không nghĩa gì Nghĩ
thế à
Em đừng bảo là ra squat có bị ảnh hưởng
bởi thằng này nhá
size 3
a Master
Anh hơi bị khó một tí bài toán là ra xử
ra sự nhé
chị đã sử là à
tiếng Việt Việt Nam đồng ý ạ sau đó thì
người dùng ở đây người ta chọn đồng tiền
EU thì rõ ra mình sẽ biến đổi các đồng
tiền đấy Sau đó mình mới hiển thị đầu
tiên ở đây đúng không ạ Giống mình muốn
làm bài toán dễ rồi mình chỉ cho phép
người dùng nhập một ra đời một loại đồng
tiền thôi thì mình sẽ dễ xử lý còn nếu
mà giờ sửa ông muốn chia khó giống như
kiểu Tôi đang chơi khó ngay bây giờ cứ
sẽ chỉ với ông cách như này
ít nhất là
chắc thứ nhất là để về việc chọn đồng
tiền cũng như là ngôn ngữ ngôn ngữ nữa
nhé
bộ phim sẽ phải như sau nói gì
em gà riêng với ngôn ngữ đã lằng nhằng
đấy Tôi quên mất là bây giờ sang bên này
giao diện của bên A người dùng rồi nên
thành ra mà mình không phải giống như
bên A bên admin nữa là mình thích để
ngôn ngữ gì đây này mình sẽ nên phải có
hai ngôn ngữ thôi ông ạ và ngôn ngữ là
tiếng Anh và tiếng Việt rồi chẳng hạn
nhớ là tôi có cái cờ ở đây mình nghỉ thì
cờ bay rồi nhé
nó không có cái có cái phút Ơ mày
Ý tôi nói nghe nói không có cái chọn
ngôn ngữ quấy xem nhé
không có cái nào đẹp mày nghỉ tại sao
của mình khi kéo xuống trông nó tệ nhỉ
Ừ Lụa
anh em dpad có vẻ nó không có mấy cái
chọn ngôn ngữ ở đây giống như cậu Cái
bên à hyper
Ừ mình thể copy về giao diện bên hai vợ
được nhưng mà không biết sửa CS nó bị
sao không ạ
Anh
Hợp ơi mình có cái chọn ngay ở đây này
Đấy mình thể đẩy nó xuống dưới cũng được
Tôi thích để nó xuống dưới hyper-v
à à
anh không kịp rút đau nhưng mà lại mình
chọn này
anh em cái lỗi gì
thì mình sẽ hiển thị Lâm cái đây để mình
chọn
Ừ ông muốn nói ở dưới
ờ ờ muốn nó dưới kiểu flash
Ừ tôi sẽ thử copy xem à
Ừ hi vọng không phải sửa ngoài sửa giao
diện à
cô gái là
cho mình đặt tên nó thằng này là gì nhỉ
Ừ lát manual
à à
một cái máy nuôi trôi nổi không ạ à
Dần hàng ngày
rồi nó kệ bootstrap.min này có này xa
này chẳng qua là
à
Tôi đang cần flash ở đây sẽ là
à à
Anh xóa đi này Speed No No
Chú Voi Xinh
Ừ nó sau đó thì bắt Tân
và dai
đi xe 50 Tết đi sợ này
anh chàng Nhìn cái gì cả
ạ bấm bấm được cái sẽ nhìn cái gì đó
đúng không ngắm nhìn nhé
Ờ Ờ đợi tí nhá gì nhá đầy bạn trước là
nó sẽ có cái á
hình ảnh
hình ảnh 10 quốc gia
Ừ cái á
cho đến giờ mình lấy ảnh rồi à
Anh Hợp ơi mình đây
hi vọng chỉ có mỗi vài cái này mới đặt
ở các trường hỗ
trợ không Tạm thời cho có tiếng Việt đi
ừ
ở xa mà
ở ga không không cần có thể lên cái cần
mà lấy được
Em
hãy kiểu gì chồng không mấy cái ai cần
Âm Nhạc
cần đâu hết
nhà báo sao
cả ngày có
a portion
Ừ ok for all i
có ai Cần Thơ
ô hay dùng phiên bản nào nhỉ
a 4.7 luôn ạ ok
à à
không sao rồi đậu xanh
anh không Dạ Em có phải có nhỉ
em lừa rồi nó xâm mà không có
à à
Ừ Rồi sao
Ừ anh đi có mình đâu chèn thêm cái phone
của Mortal Anh cần đâu yêu những cái này
không phải đâu nha không chữ đấy
Ê mày đang có mỗi phồn hoa sớm rồi
xe lửa
Ừ được rồi
cha
mẹ ai cần nhớ Trước anh cần có mấy cái
biểu tượng này mà
Thật là vãi chưởng à
à à
chào vậy
anh nghe sẽ ra
Ừ anh tên Hải sẽ ra gì nhé ạ
a black Watch
ờ ờ
ạ Có mỗi mấy loại cờ thôi
em nhớ mấy cái này đều có cờ quốc gia
rồi nhỉ
xe tải Mẹ chơi cái trò lộ hơn mà mình
tự nhập luôn cả icon nhập luôn cả biểu
tượng vào
như này
tao đợi mày về copy về
anh không không được
ở
[Tiếng cười]
đây cách thử à
The Flash
bác ăn chi
cho ai cần
à à
anh không ta
Ừ vợ USD ra nhé x
thứ hai phải viết cẩu vn
ờ ờ Canada
à à
ở Canada nhiều biết ngay
flash nào
the flash có mũi đây xe lửa
xe lửa
cái thứ này nghỉ xài vậy
a medium bị chặn
này
ở nhà ông giải thích cậu bé gái
ae af pro
Ở Bắc Kinh
a ha tải về
thể cho cái à
khi đó mẹ nó lại được hợp lý mới hay
nước rồi mà a web
anh ấy web
Anh ở tiếng Anh cứ việc làm ở nha
em kêu này
mắc gì
à à
a merry kalou
anh ở đây USD
làm cái gì luôn à
thông báo hiện
đổi lại cái này
ốp lát
anh em bây giờ
mà chả được
Vì sao à bóng
này có tệ để chuẩn bị thôi
tệ thật rồi
cho nên nó lên gì nhỉ nên nên hai này
như đang bị lỗi
à vì thế được
Ừ nó như này chứ
anh đều vãi
cũng mùa này hãy chết ngay sẽ phải lấy
màu khác
anh em màu gì được nhỉ
Ừ tôi tổng cái này lên đây đó nhanh nghỉ
mệt quá Ừ tôi sẽ tổng sửa lên đỡ đợi
nghĩ nhiều
Vì sao ư
cái đấy à
30 máy C3 nó là ba chứ
là cái v3i
Vì sao được đi
nó dễ mà
khi đàn bà ơi
ờ ờ
bộ phim sex có thể à Đây đúng không
xóa đi này à
à à
rằng bà Ngọc
ờ ờ
thì nó sẽ có class ôtô này a-class night
to night
anh cái thẻ bên là để mà sẽ chỉ ra cái ở
bên cạnh rồi mà
Ừ tôi không biết mày ông ngắm nhanh mà
tôi không
thì
tại sao ạ
Ừ nó xin lỗi Anh xin lỗi
thật bớt này đi ạ
Con gì nhỉ
Ừ Ok sau đó thì ra cái dưới này thôi dễ
diện tôi tôi chiều mày Ông nhắn đấy
phải bấm linh đến cái tím mình sẽ xử lý
nhé để đi tiếng Anh tiếng Việt đấy
ờ ờ
ở đây
Ừ
nó
thì đầu tiên khi mình bấm vào đầu tiên
mặc định Tiếng Anh ngay đúng không mặc
định tiếng Anh này thì đầu tiên mình
phải sửa lại toàn bộ những cái mắc định
Tiếng Anh ngay đã Thì tôi cứ xóa mấy cái
nút này đi
Anh ở thuật mái nút này sửa xong cái nút
này không muốn chặn thì sửa sao mình sẽ
có cái ví dụ ví dụ đầu tiên nhất nhé
I Found You need này chẳng hạn ra sự thế
là kiểu
kiểu à
Ừ thôi cứ phải quan từ đi cái tiêu đề
hay mà thì
có cách cách để mà mình sẽ viết theo
kiểu dạng là Loco A nó gọi localization
à
ở đây ngoài localization thì mình sẽ
viết theo thuộc dạng mà theo đa ngôn ngữ
thì cách viết của mình sẽ là cái cách nó
cười đi hiểu ngay thì sẽ xét nó lại sẽ
lô kết rồi lại vận
Ừ Rồi mình sẽ ghi vào trong cái mạng có
danh sách kiểu như này cách viết để cái
tiếp nó sẽ đúng kiểu như này Đợi tớ tí
viết kiểu dạng như này đây cái tin nhắn
đi ngắn nhất thì vậy Ngon nó dạy cách
viết nhưng ngắn nhất này à
ờ ờ
ở bài câu view này mày ông sẽ có mặc
định có thêm một ve ngày rồi mặc định có
những cái này rồi nhớ về mình sẽ thêm
những cái gì nữa sẽ thêm ở đây ví dụ là
mình để thêm một cái cái file file ạ
Ê mèo
sẽ đọc nó là fanpage thì sẽ ghi hết ở
trong cái fanpage này tên này
gây như này
rộ là à
cho ví dụ nhé mình để đây nó thay Thôi
được ạ ra xử thế hai thôn này
À mà tôi sẽ là
I I want to miss Nga tráng chẳng hạn đấy
sôi bên này
thì mình sẽ sửa lại cái cách đi của mình
sẽ là
như này
à à khi mở ra ngày nó ghi sai thủ ngày
xong rồi nhé
à à
em ở xa nhà music
30 cái xuân rồi nhỉ À phải fanpage xong
rồi mới thay thổ của tôi
mặc định ở tiếng Anh là mặc định lên Alo
Tại sao thì mới ông phải sẽ thường là
mấy ông sẽ chỉ nhận trong con fix Chỉnh
áp này à
Khi mà mình sẽ có đây mình sẽ có cái
khái niệm là như này em mặc định là nếu
không tìm được thì nó sẽ trở về từ nhanh
còn mặc định lúc đầu tìm tiếng của mình
sẽ là tiếng gì Hãy cho cơ Thế thì ở đây
ở đây tôi Giả sử tôi sẽ giúp Porsche hay
ngôn ngữ thì tôi sẽ đặt tên là đẹp nó là
ngay chẳng hạn
ở ngay đi tôi sẽ đổi cái này lại hình
ảnh ai không sao ông sửa cái chỗ này
không sao ngờ ông phải biết cách sửa
không Không nhìn nó thành có xa
sau đó thì bên bên cái
I left menu ở Xóa sưởi nhá Ừ
à à
Ừ cái vừa nãy là nữa V3 đúng không ạ
biến đổi ngôn ngữ thì mình sẽ làm theo
đúng kiểu dạng ngay
mình sẽ ra gọi đây nó một cái router để
mà đổi ngôn ngữ Tôi sẽ đặt tên rồi tôi
mắc định mà nhảy ở bên A không phải ăn
đi cần đâu nên nhảy bến quét được là sửa
chưa đăng ký vẫn để cho đăng ký đăng
nhập vẫn có thể làm được
tủ lạnh xong rồi truyền cái lô kết lên
như thế này
ấn vào đây mình sẽ ra xử mình không cần
tạo controller không chịu nghe máy
Chị Minh chỉ xử lý luôn ở bên à router
cả nghe được không sao cả
chị sẽ và con thích ngay Vì gọi đến
thằng con phi kia sau đó thì mình sẽ có
áp xong rồi mình sẽ gọi đến lâu kết như
này
mình khai báo các biến áp này Đấy ngồi
mình sẽ kiểm tra đấy thôi thì báo lỗi
nha
đi học lại chụp cháu lắm
Ừ nếu trong trường hợp mà không không
không gọi không gọi được đến kể
Ừ để xem nhé
anh nhá Cái rửa chẳng quan trọng vì nhà
tôi nhớ sẽ lô kết như này Nếu không được
thì nó sẽ mắc định về cái cũ thì vậy sao
cái thằng đầu kết này sẽ bằng con fix
này
à
mà nhảy về cái thằng à cô bác này nhớ là
sử không không tìm được thì mình sẽ tìm
mình sẽ mặc định về cái thằng ngày đó
sao mình sẽ truy nã vào trong ngay
à à
khi
mở thẻ xong
Bây giờ Bây giờ để tôi thử
Em thử án Hải cho lên cho nó cái ví dụ
ra à
a language Vâng ạ
đến thằng Daughter
A lô tô ở đây sẽ là
à à
35 which all
khi bị di truyền sang mình sẽ truyền lên
một cái
ở đó là à
Anh hello
Ừ vợ đi mà
mà tại sao mày à
á nhon
được robot Tần này thành là nó không bán
được
hay để nó rồi đi thôi nhớ đầy nó dưới
cho có vẻ hiểu là có bấm đi
đầy thằng này Xuống dưới đi vậy
thế này là không bấm được
thằng cũ của nó thì
Ê thằng cũ rồi bị xóa Sư Rồng cũ rồi
a common đây vẫn còn mà không có này
tỷ lệ đi iPhone 7 đang sân sẽ số điện nó
là
Anh biết nhưng
khi cài đặt lại
à à
Ừ
cái à
ừ ừ
à à
a Metal Icons
đổi để Index chồng ngoại
tiếng Anh cho tôi rõ ràng mình đang ở
tiếng Anh đấy thì
thì mình sẽ khi mình làm này xong kiểu
như mình sẽ điều hướng quay trở lại Việt
ơn Black bác có như không trữ gì xảy ra
cả
à à
thế nhưng bây giờ ra sự là mình sẽ nổi
nó sang tiếng Việt thì xem là copy được
mấy ngày
em giả sử bây giờ lỗi nha Tôi phải tạo 1
file tiếng Việt thì mày ông ấy dễ hình
dung được sẽ tạo một cái thư mục ở đây
là vi như này
à mà
ở TP
đi sói mình sẽ copy này
thế thôi sao Bây giờ ấn tiếng Việt
Ừ đúng nhạc đúng mà
đây à
video này đẩy sang đây
It is fun đúng rồi
ở đợ tôi một tí Đợi tao một tí nhà xét
cái kia nó không tác dụng xét nấu kết ở
đây không tác dụng gì
a b d e f
Nha
mình đang bị sai à
Anh sex loake
Ô thế mình sẽ tạo 1 cái lô kết ở đây nữa
mặc định nó sẽ lúc đầu là ln
Sau đó mình gửi xét được Chắc thế
ạ
ạ sau đó mình xét
Ê cu Lân
Quỳnh tô cấp I
ừ ừ
Thử xem ngay chuyện này xem biết đó nha
à à
thể do tôi không chạy cái
Lê Văn search dân số của nó hôm trước đó
đang nghĩ trong hợp đấy nó Tôi không
chạy cái à pp
thì sân shop của nó lên thành ra mấy cái
ở non không lưu lại
để tôi thử phách
à à
Happy cân
Sao lại nghỉ
là nó chơi cơ chế là dùng nó lưu lại
trong to scan xong rồi Cứ mỗi lần nó sẽ
gọi to Kenny cơ nó không phải làm kiểu
mai anh không được cho không được không
thích
á
anh sex Như Lai
tạm thời thời thời điểm này thì nó được
thôi còn là
bộ set ở bên này thành ra không được
tính nữa nghĩa mình phải lưu lại trong
thí sinh hoặc là lưu lại trong nha
xứ Xuân Hoa Cà mình yêu lại trong Token
gì để lên ở thì được gì nhé
Ừ tối Hồi đấy Cho tôi xem cái phiên bản
này cơ này ờ ờ ờ
làm một cái đi mất 3 này Paris này
ở sông rồi language
I look alike
a lô
xe tay ga xịn xịn cục sẽ tải về máy
không xem cái này để mở hỗ trợ việc và
ông làm soạn thảo mấy cái tặng kia là cả
dịch ra nhiều ngôn ngữ nhà luôn
Hôm qua tôi tôi lại tin tưởng khu đô vào
cái
mà cái đó của mình rồi Thằng này cũng
chả tác dụng vẫn là quay quần đi Hãy
quay lại cái này à
nếu thể tra về cái vụ là monty nộp
horizone nó sẽ đừng có đọc của tài liệu
của nó anh xem về ông ấy nói là thằng
khác nói thì nó sẽ bảo lưu lại trong sân
hóa lừa ở trong Token
không
u80 cái file các thứ thứ
khi truyền sex người ngon
à Xong rồi mít the word thì mình sẽ
Cứ mỗi lần season có mình xét lại phát
nữa à ok ok
à à
Ừ thế nào chạy rồi mưa rồi
khi lại tạo một cái
chị sẽ
cho tao xem
anh ở lại appss
đúng chị sẽ ra xin
khi sex
ờ ờ lúc
Nghe ca nhạc
Ê mèo nhại post thì mày không hệ đi rồi
này nhanh nhá Nó hepl của nó được như
nhau thôi
một họ nghĩ được well nữa
Anh thề luôn xét lại về à
anh sex xem lại về lô kết
à à
em copy cái này
anh ạ
ở ngã sẽ xong
thế thôi nhỉ Chắc được đấy à
anh
số tiền ỉa trông thấy Bây giờ tôi chỉ
muốn xóa ngay đi nó qua chở tiếng Anh
không ạ Giờ tôi chạy ở đây
a store set ở sân
cả những gì ở Sài đây sex Út
Út chứ không phải bút lại lỗi tôi
nó
cái đứng nhờ mới khai báo này Nhưng mình
phải phải bảo nó trông Canon để mở cái
lên khi mà chạy vào web nó sẽ luôn Chạy
thêm này
a cho xe mà chạy thì em không biết là
quen à
Ừ nó lại trang này
a mắt có thằng này sẽ vào
nick đúng mà
khi sex
à à
hình như thằng áp lịch cần này nó bỏ qua
tất cả thằng quét rồi mới sau đó là
thằng nhà
thằng Bin the weather loop trang web nó
luôn mình luôn Chạy qua phòng web và nhỉ
này nhỉ
xem Tại sao
Ừ tôi thì đúng là mình đã khai báo ở bên
A phải đô là mình
Em có biết the weather like in the way
này
ở nhà web
Đấy thêm này về sau thêm biết the Wells
ăn dưới nữa cũng được
lưu mỗi xin thật ra là không nên lưu mẫu
xây dựng hiện nay mà mà mình lưu lại ở
trong nhà
a cookie lưu lại trên máy người dùng này
nó sẽ ổn hơn
Ừ để người dùng lần sau vào lại trang
thì nó không cần phải chọn lại ngôn ngữ
nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ đấy thì 3 ô tô đổi sáng Inax nó sẽ
xanh như này trả lại sang sẽ vẫn sẽ Iraq
thế này sẽ sang ngay tại sao nó vẫn sẽ
tiếng Việt không ạ Cũng chưa ạ thì cái
Pocket này không phải tôi vừa rồi tôi
thêm vào cho vui Có khi là ra hai a
Ừ ông ông sẽ phải trả những cái lệnh này
để mà
khi sex
tủ lạnh này
Ừ để lưu lại
a
Translation And I
cả cái tắt view đâu con fix thì ông thể
lắc đít là cái tâm con fix rồi sau đó
thì
ở
Messenger Rebels à à
ô ồ có cả Bây giờ có cả tự động dịch của
Google Translate api luôn này rồi xịn
thế ngồi tôi dùng không có cái đâu
Anh không biết cài cái này nhau luôn xem
ạ ạ
qua à
này để mà import-export như thế này
trước khi nó sẽ bản chất là nó sẽ cho
ông cái router để mà ông chuyên Compaq
nó pro tơ này nó tờ này
ờ ờ ờ
Ở nhà mà ông Con thích cái Translate của
ông
ông thầy cô đăng nhập ở nhà ở thời tiết
ờ ờ quên
buộc phải đăng nhập nhà thờ ông thấy bỏ
điều đấy trong này à
thế này đây này
bỏ qua điều đấy trong mày
a porta Xbox có thử thử ra
Đợi tí nha Ăn Tết này Đấy nó xảy ra kiểu
ngay ông lại thêm một cái language mới
nữa hoặc à giúp ở bên au này bên em bên
tiếng Anh có rồi tiếng Việt chưa có ông
này thêm ở đây sửa sai rồi em ạ Cái
không còn tư lại nha đấy
hay dùng ra Switch cùng Yuri làm tất cả
đúng hay sao mà khi mà xong hết toàn bộ
các thứ cho ông sẽ entreat như thế này
để mà suốt cả này vào Wifi
language của mình để nó sẽ để về sau ông
inna sẽ có là sự như thế này
Ừ
ông sẽ thấy là nó sẽ có thêm cái file ở
Sing a cho mấy ông
em nhậu à
Em không hiểu nữa vọng chịu tôi mới giải
thích nha mà để mua tháng nay rồi đại
khái như thế với tôi dùng Tôi dùng cái
này để mà kiểu mình làm chỉ cho làn hai
ngôn ngữ thôi này
Ê mày cái bên nhau này tao thử không cần
những giận nó về sau mình sẽ có thêm vài
cái ở đây nữa không ạ Rồi mình sẽ thêm
kì đây này
anh em mình áp một cái ở đây này Nó
ngoại trú rất nhiều sẽ làm thêm vài cái
kia Ở đây các thử
ạ sau đó mình sẽ umbridge để mà số ta gì
chưa
vẫn phải cốt rồi nếu không sẽ phải cốt
để mà sửa mày cái đoạn đấy Từ Cái đây là
reset lại Nuti set này có thiếu tướng
không phải sửa lại nội dung
ừ ừ
xổ số đài lúc quay lại chẳng hạn đấy
không phải sửa lại hết toàn bộ những cái
tựa đề bữa này dù đầy địa điểm này
location địa điểm này là sử nha tôi sẽ
bắt tôi sẽ thử làm cho mình xem nhé Ok
sân khấu ngoại
mà tự động Translate hộ mình
chị sẽ location
ở lại
anh ạ
cho hạ thế
Kể chuyện cô hàng ngày à
A One Piece
chuẩn đô faison à thì tại sao
Ừ cái này đã
hình ảnh ở nhá nhiều nhé
thì tại sao bạn đi
cho nó hiểu rồi mà nó học những là mấy
ông cập nhật Translate ở trong cái trang
này top nó thì sẽ được giảm à
em đi chơi dễ trúng thưởng
chỉ mỗi tội hơi tốn thời gian để ngồi
sửa toàn bộ những cái kiểu tựa đề cho
thứ thành kiểu kiểu biến như này thôi
ngoại
ờ ờ ờ
gian ấy vẫn chưa ngồi làm được cái sợ gì
cả Để xem tối Thế còn giờ cái gì làm
nghỉ à
anh không nhỉ Hôm nay có thì nghỉ sớm
xong rồi để mấy ông hấp thụ toàn bộ kiến
thức hôm nay ở kênh tiếp à Hôm nay mình
đã dậy rồi những cái gì nhỉ Tôi chẳng
biết mẹ đã dậy thì sao
từ cái bớt rồi này
diện
Ê mày chưa có gì ở dạng mấy
Âm Nhạc
cô dạy Cãi
A gọi tôi sẽ dậy cái việc ở lấy Token để
mà lưu lại ở trong nhà lưu lại ở trong
lưu lại trên đâu còn mấy ông biết rồi mà
dùng hàng p bình thường thôi để lưu lại
các em sau đó khi mới vào trang thì sẽ
phát từ cái top game Nếu mà xin không có
đúng không ạ
Ừ
thì tôi ra sự nhé
Ê mày
thế này
có điều ở trong sân
à à
ca nhạc ok là gì quên rồi
set-cookie
Có mà xe máy xe Coffee
sẽ dán cô kia nó là lâu kết như này
thằng ạ ạ
thì mình sẽ đàn
Ừ nó là
thời gian gửi ngay
à Xong rồi lúc mà giờ sự là nếu mà không
lấy được cái này cũng không có
hỗ trợ xem nhé
em
gửi tiền bằng cái này
mà trống
chế độ kết này
thì bắt đầu mình lấy tiếp cái thằng mà
ghét Cookie ft này
I highly em chẳng biết là có biết không
khi không có
ô mai quất
Âm Nhạc
ừ ừ
máy kiểu nông dân gỗ hôi hội chữa vậy
cô kết này bằng
Ê mày cơ kia
chạy ngay
à à
ờ ờ
phải kiểm tra xem mà có tồn tại ở trong
cái này không này Không nên mặc định sẽ
có bác như này quay trở lại cái á cái
kiểu Giả sử cái lô cái này không hợp lệ
mình sẽ quay trở lại cái lâu kết mặc
định này
à à
là kiểu định có giá trị rồi thì mình sẽ
phẳng luôn có khi như này thế là xong
Ông Bà mình có thể xét luôn cả cái
Ừ ráng Cookie tăng lên hình 30 ngày ngay
lấy trong sân ra nếu là sử là nhớ ra sự
là không lấy được ngắm rừng lấy từ ông
kia là ngon dán thứ thứ và tôi sẽ thử ví
dụ cho mày không xe đầu tiên gì à
Ừ thì tôi không lưu lại trong chiếc sân
nữa là sự tôi sẽ
đi Cho xin đi sẽ là
ờ ờ
ở season
a real Nhớ lắm Plus vậy
ở
khu season or đấy Bây giờ có Đây rõ ràng
là bên trong này mấy ông thấy là trong
sân nó có nhé
ba lô Kitty đúng không Tôi sửa đổi nó là
như này
the Wacky đi season bị mất rồi đúng
không bị mất rồi nhé
sau đó thì
à mà không tìm thấy ở đây nghĩa Cookie
bản chất mình không có
nhà mình có xe Coffee rồi nhỉ Ông có nhé
à
vì vậy Tĩnh
à à
khi tôi vừa cách tôi vừa
sunfresh Mình là xóa hết rồi
season flash ở Kiểu gì nó phải có nhỉ
Mình xem à
em nghe chuyện thời gian Lê Sang ờ ờ
à vì tôi đồng ý
anh ạ
ở lại
thì tại sao
nhà xe Quốc kỳ ở đây
à à Nhờ vẫn đi uống sữa gì vậy
Ừ đợi tí nhé Để tí nha à
à à
Vision không có này ngoại nhà này
Âm Nhạc Ê pete ơi Hai có lấy được từ kỳ
đâu khi ta vẫn có mà
Ồ vãi cả chưởng
ghế Coffee
area as the way nó
ừ ừ
chị sẽ làm như thế nào
kỳ là language nè
em có về Hải Dương Minh
em yêu kiểu khác rồi
3000 dùng hàn logo kiểu dạng là sẽ có
kia gọi ngay
bạn chất là như thế Mình phải tra chính
là liệu của Lara đã khi
à à
sau khi quét
Ừ anh chỉ có
Ừ biết rồi
anh có tận hai cái ở đây mà
I would only chào
đúng mà
à à
Ừ cái này là and clip
Anh
mệt quá
a basic attacks in Oki telephones
dùng để hankooki của nó sao mà
Ồ vãi cả chưởng
a minute ở đây sẽ là như thế này mít
luôn á lý
T60 nhân
à 24 x
cho tao mượn à
ê ê đi Ở đây là mà không chạy đến cái
xét koki Ừ tí đại thiện thì ẩn hết sử đó
ngoài đấy à
Lúc đầu nó vào xe cũ Kia được này
ô kê
hai kỳ Giờ tội của tôi là một cái gì đó
thôi
anh không còn làm cái bình thường đã
Anh xóa đi nha xe tải nhạc
Ừ nó
ạ sau đó thì tôi ghét ta thử xem nhé
anh vẫn không ra
Ừ địt
đặc biệt
sướng không có này à
Ơ cái thằng ở đây đi vậy
à à
ơi mẹ chưa ạ
luôn à
từ ngày do về season Plus này
anh không có mệt quá ờ season ok
anh alo ai thêm ngày Minute đấy Thật
tham cộng với nhà nha à
anh không
em không ra
em vừa rồi
A mạch
ở đài Mini này
A mạch mềm contrack
Ừ
Kiểu gì nó vẫn ngồi sau đây này mày chưa
à à
Ừ anh thử gọi hàng set rồi mà
nhà mình có xét
vợ
yêu nhỉ
Anh HKT Singapore
ô
ạ ở thấy rằng ngành đấy rồi làm đây bạn
Vậy em làm để chơi dễ trúng thưởng cho
đời thanhthản ờ
lại không có kỳ cuối cùng người ấy cả nụ
hồng Mạnh Quỳnh ở đây đó đơn giản
anh alo
à à
Ừ rồi tiếng Việt đây rồi gì đấy
38 người đã hôm sau tình cũ kỹ sau mình
qua
xe hơi tốn thời gian cho mấy cái thằng
đâu đâu đấy
đấy hoạt tính năng quan trọng Chúng ta
sẽ bỏ qua vụ này Ok
Cũng sao thời cả thậm chí mấy ông có thể
bắt chước cái này để làm cái chim đổi
sang kiểu màu giao diện một tối cái gì
đó tôi không quan tâm nhưng mà nói chung
lại khá thôi chỉ cho mình phong cách để
mà để mà cái đổi sang ngôn ngữ các thứ
đồ ngoại tạm người đã mày hơn mình tôi
đang ốm trở lại ốm lại rồi mẹ ạ ạ
bộ đèn hôm hôm sau tôi sẽ chỉ mày có
người cái sớm này Hôm Sao chẳng còn cái
gì để ngồi nói nó cha không cho nói cái
sợ mình anh thôi hôm nay phải nói qua
cái lâu kết này nhanh rồi mà để mà mình
sửa cái tựa đề chứ ngoại trữ chứ không
phải làm chán chê rồi bắt đầu đi ngồi
sửa lại toàn bộ váy biến thì mới hiển
thị ra thì vỡ mồm đấy nghĩa mình mình
nên làm cái nếu mà mình muốn làm đa ngôn
ngữ thì mình phải làm cái này sớm để mà
để mà đổi nó sang hàng nhiều ngôn ngữ
các thể thử ngay nó ngủ sớm chứ không
phải ạ về sau ông ngồi sữa vỡ mồm không
tìm tất cả các tách ở trong trên trang
ông sửa không thì đi đâu đấy thôi chào
các bạn nha mày nghỉ sự nghỉ sớm đã
Ừ rồi tôi còn chưa nói vụ đổi tiếng Anh
sang tiêu đề đã thay đổi cơ đấy chắc
chắn Phải dùng cái kia của thằng kia hai
à Mình thấy da mình có thể dùng để hàm
để mà đổi chữ tiếng Việt có dấu hình chữ
tiếng Việt không dấu cũng có
nhưng mà thôi kệ đi Kệ đi buộc
Xin chào mấy ông nha